quanti di voi posseggono uno smartphone
alzate la mano ok domanda sbagliata
quanti di voi non posseggono uno
smartphone
direi nessuno quasi nessuno nel 2039 il
rapporto sarà totalmente invertito
nessuno avrà uno smartphone
comunicherete col resto del mondo a mani
libere di relazione rete col resto del
mondo in una maniera che oggi è
inimmaginabile e questo sarà possibile
grazie a dispositivi piccoli così che
potranno essere contenuti in una
scatolina come questa
sarà tutta un'altra esperienza il
rapporto col resto del mondo col mondo
che vi circonda esperienza nel senso
latino del termine dal bareback speri ri
l'acquisizione con tutti i sensi del
mondo che vi circonda sia esso reale o
virtuale fisico o virtuale come un buon
bicchiere di vino che prima di berlo
prima di essere bevuto va assaporato con
gli occhi col naso tutti i sensi
coinvolti di questo voglio parlarvi oggi
di come le comunicazioni wireless nel
2039 vi consentiranno di vivere questa
piena esperienza
lo smartphone è stato inventato
fondamentalmente da una grande azienda
americana che ha lanciato nel 2007 il
primo di una lunghissima e fortunata
serie lo smartphone che cos'è
fondamentalmente è il touch screen lo
schermo che si tocca le icone che
possono essere mosse con il vostro dito
in realtà è una tecnologia quella del
touchscreen che sta per essere superata
verrà presto superata da cosa da due
tecnologie
la prima gli ologrammi in tre dimensioni
la callas la callas canta oggi sui nei
teatri di tutto il mondo insieme al cast
revere non è la callas che canta e il
suo ologramma in 3d le aziende che
costruiscono dispositivi oggi ci
promettono che entro pochi anni
tutti i dispositivi saranno in grado di
proiettare nello spazio davanti a voi
tutte le immagini che oggi sono sullo
schermo e quindi li avrete tutte davanti
a voi nello spazio che potrete
manipolare la seconda tecnologia piccole
telecamere magari nascoste in qualche
gioiello negli occhiali in grado con un
algoritmo di elaborare i vostri gesti di
elaborare quello che state con le mani
facendo in quello spazio davanti a voi
ecco che le due cose insieme rendono
inutile allo schermo ed ecco quindi che
di colpo non ci sarà più bisogno di uno
schermo e dispositivo potrà essere
piccolo così sarà realtà o fantascienza
quello che vi sto proponendo e qualcosa
che ha un suo possibile futuro
beh per immaginare il futuro bisogna
cercare di guardare nel passato quindi
facciamo un escursus sul passato il
primo sistema di comunicazione mobile è
stato inventato negli stati uniti nel
1976 il telefonino se così vogliamo
chiamarlo se vi va per telefonare
la trasmissione di voce nient'altro poi
negli anni 90 è arrivata la seconda
generazione
negli anni 90 mi sono laureato
all'inizio degli anni 90 e appassionato
di scienza di wireless mi sono dedicato
alla ricerca sulle comunicazioni
wireless ascoltando gli esperti coloro
che sapevano predire il futuro come
cerchiamo di fare qui oggi negli anni 90
come dicevo arrivate nella seconda
generazione il gsm che ancora era per
telefonare trasmissione di voce ma in
forma digitale crittografata così che
nessuno potesse intercettare le nostre
comunicazioni privacy finalmente la
privacy
in quegli anni qualcuno inventato gli
sms vi ricordate i brevi messaggi di
testo 160 caratteri ormai superati
bene gli esperti quando la sms è stato
messo sul mercato hanno detto servizio
di nicchia non li userà nessuno
pochi anni dopo si trasmettevano in
italia ogni giorno un milione di sms
previsione sbagliata
quando chiede gli studenti in aula
ragazzi quanti di voi fanno
videochiamate la risposta è zero
previsione sbagliata il 3g è stato
utilizzato fondamentalmente per navigare
in internet ma gli esperti non ci hanno
azzeccato poi arrivato il 4g e siamo nel
decennio attuale quello che sta finendo
velocità di trasmissione senza sempre
maggiori immagini video video video eh
sì 4g sarà la tecnologia per le
videochiamate
no il 4g è stata la tecnologia per i
social perché le usiamo fondamentalmente
per andare sui social previsione
sbagliata
insomma tutti coloro che nei passati 30
anni nel mio settore hanno cercato di
predire il futuro non ci hanno azzeccato
praticamente mai e quindi qui siamo un
po di guai
d'altro canto daniel kahneman premio
nobel per l'economia ma psicologo in
questo bellissimo libro che vi
suggerisco di leggere tra le tantissime
cose che racconta dice anche e spiega
perché quando si tratta di predire il
futuro
coloro che sbagliano di più sono gli
esperti e allora siamo nei guai perché
io sono stato invitato in qualità di
esperto e vi devo proporre la mia
previsione del futuro e quindi si tratta
di chiedersi qual è il modo migliore è
quello che ho cercato di fare in questi
giorni in cui mi sono presenti preparato
per questo che è stato immaginare
trovare un modo per predire il futuro
come saranno le comunicazioni uguale se
il 2039 ci sono due modi secondo me per
predire il futuro
il primo il primo è quello di chiedere a
chi lo sta inventando chiedere a chi lo
sta facendo
in altri termini osservare ciò su cui le
grandissime aziende e le top del settore
delle comunicazioni wireless stanno
investendo loro stanno investendo su
l'internet delle cose
l'internet james lyautey questo è il 5 g
prima di tutto il 5 g la tecnologia che
di cui si parla oggi e che sarà la
tecnologia degli anni venti gli anni che
stanno arrivando il decennio che sta
arrivando
oggetti che saranno connessi alla rete
fornendo grandissime quantità di
informazioni si parla di 50 miliardi di
oggetti connessi alla rete entro pochi
anni o oggetti che si parleranno tra di
loro c 30 di genti in cui cestini
dell'immondizia avvertiranno quando sono
pieni e vuoti così da ottimizzare la
raccolta dell'immondizia e noi troveremo
sempre cestini vuoti lampioni
intelligenti che si accenderanno
soltanto quando un'auto una persona
passerà sotto lampione così da non
sprecare energia ridurre il consumo
delle risorse di questo pianeta
oppure auto connesse auto connesse
connesse alla rete tramite il 5 g per
cosa beh la mia auto potrà sapere in
anticipo se un semaforo sta per
diventare verde o rosso così da poter
gestire al meglio l'accelerazione la
frenata avere un traffico più fluido
plotoni di automobili in autostrada che
viaggeranno a 130 chilometri all'ora
a pochi metri di distanza una dall'altra
ma in totale sicurezza perché quando la
prima davanti in testa al plotone frena
l'altra lo sa pochi millisecondi dopo e
può frenare di conseguenza magari in
maniera automatica
quindi un traffico più sicuro a bologna
nei nostri laboratori
stiamo lavorando insieme una grande
azienda del settore automobilistico una
di quelle che abbiamo in regione emilia
romagna quelli che fanno le macchine che
costano molto e stiamo connettendosi
alla rete la macchina per cosa perché le
future macchine anche quelle super
veloci avranno motore ibrido elettrico e
a combustione e i cicli termici
se la macchina sa tutto di ciò che sta
per avvenire attorno ad essa i cicli
termici possono essere ottimizzati così
che per esempio quando si ci si
avvicinano alla città si produce zero
emissioni una città più pulita e poi
l'industria 40 la possibilità di
applicare le tecnologie del 5 g l agli
impianti industriali così che robot
macchine sistemi meccanici possono
funzionare al meglio e magari in maniera
più sicura a bologna nel
il nostro laboratorio e questa è una
cosa che stiamo facendo in
collaborazione con altri due gruppi di
ricerca dei colleghi benini e costanzo
abbiamo sviluppato per un'azienda
un'importante azienda del settore
dell'automazione questo oggettino qua
questo non a batteria
perché riceve l'energia dall'ambiente
circostante e una volta montato in certe
parti nei pezzi di una macchina sopra un
robot consente di misurarne i parametri
vitali che vengono trasmessi in tempo
quasi reale ha un'interfaccia verso un
operatore così che l'operatore sappia se
la macchina funziona bene e soprattutto
se la macchina sta per provocare danni e
così da generare un ambiente più sicuro
per l'operatore umano
insomma il 5 g l'internet delle cose è
una tecnologia ma è una tecnologia per
l'uomo è una tecnologia per l'ambiente
ma come ho detto c'è un secondo modo per
cercare di predire il futuro
tutto quello che vi ha raccontato sarà
ma cos'altro potrebbe essere il futuro
di coloro che credono nella bellezza dei
propri sogni
allora proviamo a sognare vi chiedo una
cortesia
chiudete gli occhi chiudete gli occhi
per favore fatelo vi dirò io quando
riaprirli ora immaginate una persona
lontana
a cui volete bene è una persona che non
vedete da tempo un figlio una figlia in
dottorato a bruxelles un fidanzato una
fidanzata che vive in un'altra città un
genitore che è rimasto nel sud mentre
voi siete venuti nel nord a lavorare e
volete sentire relazionarvi con questa
persona cosa fate
prendete il telefono fate una
videochiamata voce video vi basta
a me non basterebbe io vorrei qualcosa
di più io vorrei poter sentire l'odore
della sua pelle
vorrei poter accarezzare il suo viso e
sentire la morbidezza della sua pelle
aprite gli occhi vorrei una piena
esperienza come se quella persona fosse
davanti a me qui ed ora
ora il 5 g potrà farlo
non lo so certamente sta provando a
farlo ma manca ancora qualcosa manca
anche l'empatia cos'è l'empatia
se lo chiedete uno psicologo vi dirà
l'empatia è quella situazione per cui si
riesce a sentire come sente l'altro
vedere dal punto di vista dell'altro
no ma io intendo cos'è l'empatia da un
punto di vista fisico
dal punto di vista fisico l'empatia è la
trasmissione di onde cerebrali
il nostro cervello emette onde
elettromagnetiche
e quando c'è una relazione di empatia
con la persona che abbiamo davanti
queste onde elettromagnetiche si
sincronizzano in fase frequenza quella e
l'empatia allora bisogna trasmettere
oltre la voce oltre all'immagine
oltre al tatto all'olfatto anche le onde
cerebrali potrà farlo e 5 g il 5 di una
rete fulminea che trasmette in umile
secondo grandi quantità di dati
potenzialmente potrebbe farlo
qualcuno sta cominciando a lavorare in
quella direzione
voglio farvi vedere un breve filmato è
un filmato realizzato da un mio collega
e amico del king's college a londra il
professor misha dall air che un anno fa
ha postato su youtube questo video è il
video di una del primo concerto via 5g
realizzato al mondo aveva una rete
prototipale 56 fatta insieme una grande
azienda e
e l'ha utilizzata per un concerto lui
oltre che professore e il pianista
suonava il piano a berlino la figlia
adolescente cantava a londra mille
chilometri di distanza ed era presente
in teatro come ologramma
ascoltiamoli
si risale
[Musica]
così
sergio
[Musica]
in giro
anche questo è 5g oltre all'internet
delle cose la trasmissione di emozioni
di sentimenti
ora io non so se 5g farà tutto questo ma
se non lo facesse allora potrebbe farlo
il seggi quello che verrà nel successivo
decennio negli anni trenta in alcuni
posti del mondo in alcuni laboratori
anche noi a bologna stiamo cominciando a
costruirlo e 6 g come lo vogliamo
costruire io non so come sarà il seggi
so come voglio che non sia voglio che
come che non sia come in blade runner 49
dove il protagonista cerca di avere una
relazione con un ologramma della sua
partner virtuale che in realtà non è una
cosa reale il 6 g per me deve portare
l'uomo al centro sia nel rapporto con le
macchine con robot sia nel rapporto con
le altre persone deve umanizzare il
robot in modo che si comportino loro
come diciamo noi e non è viceversa e
deve permetterci di raggiungere quella
piena esperienza di cui vi ho parlato in
questo talk ed è questo che sto cercando
di proporre ai miei studenti ai miei
dottorandi all'università di bologna a
fare in modo che ciò che studiamo si
applichi per un mondo più sostenibile e
in cui l'uomo sia al centro grazie a
loro e grazie a voi
[Applauso]